finalement les petits fours qui je me
présente il n'existe pas en politique
c'est à dire tout le monde les prendre
pour rien quoi et simplement ce que je
leur propose c'est de renvoyer le
complément hommes politiques en 1980
coluche se présente à l'élection
présidentielle son programme
représentait tout ce que l'on entend pas
de toute façon au programme et très très
simple je suis un candidat nul et je
veux recueillir les voix des
abstentionnistes et gevrey qui montre
combien ils sont et pourquoi ils font ça
quoi en quelques sortes
parce qu'en fait ils sont pas
représentés politiquement coin ni par la
droite ni par la gauche
des propos qui résonnent avec les
manifestations des gilets jaunes et avec
leurs revendications une pyramide
sociale où il ya un mec qui est en haut
tout seul et plus on descend plus on est
nombreux et quand on arrive en marais
vraiment dans la merde vrai qu'on remue
la merde et closer monde jusqu'en aider
mais qu'il irrite et qu'au lieu d'être
tourné vers l'extérieur du pays se
tournent à peu vers l'intérieur et qui
disent qu'est ce qu'il y a qu est ce qui
se passe qu'est ce qu'ils ont cela à
merde on leur prend tout leur pognon à
huy faudra leur laisser un peu alors le
30 octobre 1980 coluche annonce
officiellement sa candidature au théâtre
du gymnase à paris
alors comme on a voté pendant 30 ans
pour des gens compétents et intelligent
je propose aujourd'hui qu'on vote pour
un imbécile qui n'y connait rien c'est à
dire moi la campagne sera relayée par
charlie hebdo qui publie un manifeste
sous forme de provocation
j'appelle les feignants les crasseux et
drogués les alcooliques les [ __ ] les
femmes les parasites les jeunes les
vieux les artistes les taulards les
[ __ ] des apprentis les noirs et
piétons et l'arabe le français les
chevelus les fous les travestis les
anciens communistes les abstentionnistes
convaincu tous ceux qui ne comptent pas
pour les hommes politiques à voter pour
moi sur les plateaux télé qui sont rares
à le recevoir il s'affiche comme le
représentant des sans grades et des
modestes et ces mecs-là ont des
revendications et personnes sur la cub
personne personne personne y en a qui
font des promesses d'autres qui donne
des espoirs et puis à la fin du compte
on n'a rien on n'a rien rien
coluche grimpe dans les sondages
certains maires lui promettent même leur
parrainage alors finalement pourquoi
vous décidé de soutenir un clown un
fantaisiste qui peut être se moque de
vous parce que les clones inexistant au
lieu déjà et nous font pas rire la
sphère politique s'inquiète de la
popularité de coluche alors sous la
pression l'humoriste abandonne sa
candidature en mars 1980 il se retire de
la scène politique avant un retour
fracassant en 1986 avec les restos du
coeur il ya officiellement 600 mille
personnes comparé à bouffer en france
quoi tous les jours et les mecs vous dis
ça comme un chiffre et quand on leur
demande qu'est ce qu'ils vont faire pour
pour ça ils disent bas et je sais pas
alors nous on sait et on le fait voilà
mes coluche meurt trois mois après cette
interview le 19 juin 1986 dans un
accident de la route pendant plusieurs
jours une foule en deuil vient se
recueillir devant sa demeure
c'était quoi coliche rouge
un ami un parent et frère
un être unique avait pas peur de parler
sur tout
[Musique]